For the Y axis, remember we oriented it on the left, and
then also translate it margin, in the X direction.
In this case just a few pixels, and then zero in the Y.
In this case, touching the top of our chart.
So in indigo here we have the Y-axis and the X-axis which is margin over and
height down from our coordinate space which starts at 0,0.
Remember, however, when we created our Y-axis count scale.
The range was height to margin.
So even though we don't translate our y
axis as Fiji object any it only extends to margin from the top.
And before when I drew the x axis it's translated zero in the x direction.
But again if you scroll back to the timescale,
you'll remember that the timescale range went from margin to width.
So again this starts not at zero, but margin pixels over.
The call function that actually gets past the time axis and the count
axis is a way to pass the access object through the function call chain.
However understanding this JavaScript function and
its nuances is beyond the scope of these videos, but
I've left some resources in the instructor notes if you'd like to dig deeper.